another three ways that we can do this
question now let me just give you a bit
of insight back to my history with this
I always got frustrated with these
questions firms and cons in general
arrangements because I viewed them as
kind of like the opposite of calculus
with calculus you can always check it's
so easy to do not integrate right you're
just differentiating you should come
back to the same theme right and vice
versa and you know what you can do sense
check so you can and it's quite easy to
tell whether what's going on right but
with these you've come up with some
number like ninety thousand seven
hundred twenty and you're like isn't
right no way they're tried or not you go
to the back of the book but that of
course doesn't answer the big question
of well how did they know there was
ninety doesn't turn into a and not
something else okay he's the way they
know and they don't just solve it one
way if you have the right answer
you should be able to solve it one way
and then approach it in a whole
different style right and get the same
number and then approach it another way
and get the same number that's one of
the great things that mathematics no
matter which part you go you should
arrive if you used an accurate method
you should arrive at the same conclusion
okay so I'm gonna show you three ways
these are all sort of principles that
they're not about like oh okay this is a
set of steps that I can memorize because
you'll get a different question
and it will ask you a slightly different
theme these strategies will work with
this particular question but sort of
take the overall principles as much as
you cannot all refer to them in a second
okay so he comes approach number one and
I think this is probably the most common
watch is why I'm doing the first and I'm
calling this you might want to label
this impression every one is by cases by
cases now I've got to try and break down
this question and what makes it
challenging the beginning is that what
we got I think and it's supposed to be
to the right of D right but you don't
know where either of them are and so
it's like well I can't say are there are
only eight spots for M because depending
on where D is it's like well there might
not be eight spots there might be only
one spot for him and D can move anywhere
it works right but it could only move in
nine spots do you see that there are
only nine spots for it to sit so what
I'm going to do is I want to try and
think about each of the cases
but where D will be I'm not going to do
all of them because I should be able to
get patent you can see I've got three
because three is my standard way of
establishing a patent
so let's think about it nice and easy
first I mean left right so the way I
would work is I actually wouldn't write
this I'll show you at the end of this
I'll show you the way I've written up my
full solutions round the way I've talked
through it but I would actually say next
this diagram I would say fix the letter
D in position one that's what I would
actually say right now once you've done
that we deal with the restrictions one
at a time okay the other restriction is
on n right so where can it be
howdy places can it be there are yeah
they can it can be in any of these spots
right so since it can be in any of them
I actually can consider and as one of
the regular letters right so what I've
got is being n can be anywhere right
before it's like well I just got eight
letters that I can place in any way I
like
right so the way to arrange eight
letters is a factorial but don't forget
I do I do have repeats what I'm going to
do is you notice I have a pile hundred
paints every time I do this so I'm gonna
worry about the repeats right at the end
let's just think about eight minutes
okay so that's fun okay so I've got that
the next case this is the first case the
next cases well let's just shuffle to
yobbo
it's just like that so then again I
asked the question where can n be and
this time it's a little trickier
right how many spots have I got left
how many spots can it occupy any of
these spots of which there are seven
right
these two are taken well this is taken
and this one is doesn't fit our
conditions so therefore I've got seven
minutes okay so there are seven ways to
place em right after you place in how
many letters do you have left
to place you've got your placed D you
place in you've got nine minutes in
total so there are seven left to play
see all of the other spots are there any
restrictions on the other letters no and
go any way they're like so there are
seven factorial ways of placing those
final letters the remainders does that
make sense yeah that's a great as a
great question this is the case right
think back to how I arrived and this is
pause on this take your time to rush
though you must ask these questions why
did I say eight factorial because I
placed the first letter and then I
realized you know what it can be anyway
there you know like I've looked at this
is the numbers father go but aim to be
any of those so since n is just one of
the regular eight letters it's just this
problem becomes this first case just
becomes eight letters somewhere and
that's eight factorial right don't worry
about the repeats afterwards okay
another way of thinking about it is just
like I've thought here how where can we
can Envy and the answer is in eight
spots and then I have seven random
letter that I don't care where they go
thank you to go in seven factorial ways
that make sense okay and this be helpful
because it'll help you so much my patent
look okay I thought case what I've done
case two case three
where's D gonna go so the way I write
this is I would say fix the letter D in
position three okay where can n go now
there are six spots left for end right
because this one's taken and these two
are duds so I will say there are six
ways to place in and then I've got seven
more letters right that I have to place
on it and your restrictions of
they go nope so there are seven
factorial ways to place the remaining
letters do I have enough of a pattern
yeah you can see what's going to happen
right every time D shuffles over it's
it's making this number smaller because
n gets crowded out and gradually okay
now remember I said 2n convey sorry D
can be a nine spots total right because
there are actually nine spots but it
can't actually be right because if it
went over all the way to the end right
these are here how many spots are there
four in there are a zero so in fact I
can't consider as a case the ninth case
right but see how I started with eight
if I'm counting down nine times the last
one will be zero spots for N and then
you place your other minutes but it
doesn't matter because there are no ways
that fit your conditions okay but I'm
not gonna worry about that because it
doesn't add to my total okay so now that
I've done three cases I think I've
established the pattern so therefore the
total ways ah
so I have a look the first one case one
eight times seven factorial sex on
second one seven times seven factorial
and it seeks all the way down it does go
down to zero right so I'm gonna say
there's a seven factorial
every time did you notice that and then
there's eight and then this seven oh six
right now great question
why am i adding and not multiplying
these yeah because you can't have these
at the same time right the letter D
can't be in position one and in position
two simultaneously so I'm an adding
deeds not multiply to make sense and of
course I've got some repeats don't I've
got some things G factorial
all right now at this point your ever I
said are the number the number this
actually ends up being is immaterial
doesn't matter however there's something
interesting about this number if you go
ahead and you calculate it and my memory
is good I think you should find you get
exactly forty-five thousand three
hundred and sixty okay now keep in mind
we've done these earlier parts of the
question right what's the connection
between this number and the other
numbers it's exactly half of the total
exactly 1/2 of the total now that's not
always a thing that doesn't always mean
something but it should at least make
you question a little bit like is that a
coincidence that it's HUF okay
and in mathematics it's almost never a
coincidence so turn the page over turn
the page over and I'm going to I'm going
to show you another approach